today on our show we are going deep on
the last Jedi right the last Jedi still
but no Star Wars movies after that
that's all all of that and more what
else will you talk about other [ __ ] keep
watching though yeah more pictures today
on fat hand on back
[Music]
well the fat man Batman I'm Kevin Smith
mark barnard okay
the last Jedi yeah it's coming is it you
can't stop
sure I could Joe who wants to we want to
see if we want to see what ryan johnson
has up his looper sleeve man maybe he
has Luke going back in time and [ __ ]
shooting himself like a looper that's
[ __ ] awesome
we've seen some imagery mark from the
entertainment weekly's thanks to the
good people that are Tim weakly who you
used to it is my alma mater right mark
did time their night what was your title
I was the senior editor I entered the
movie reviews then I went over to the
website I did galleries and I wrote [ __ ]
to deer that kids the sound of a zipper
being opened and a huge II W [ __ ] hittin
the table hey
so II W enough blowing them mmm aw
released photos needed from Mark Hamill
on the cover from their fall movie
preview issue I believe ray on the cover
what's her name Daisy really that split
run Daisy Ridley and Mark Hamill would
last Jedi but which one is which so
there's pictures and they showed us a
new species what do we call the species
porgies Korg's Rock orcs is that what it
is
it's a pork Bo RGS thank you the pores
are coming folks and we don't know
whether they're gonna be Ewok irritating
or a bb-8 wonderful but we saw a picture
of them they look like meerkats a giant
eyes look like pop figures I hold on I'm
just a [ __ ] astonished by DB a
wonderful because that was amazing
nice job thank you very much I thought
you were gonna argue you're like BBA was
not wonderful I was getting ready to
throw this water in your face that
[ __ ] could have went so badly it
really could the [ __ ] Rollie little
droid remember when people saw the first
child like [ __ ] this and that droid was
magic who goddamn cute wheels like Jar
Jar when he did this with the lighter
one greatest moments in history there I
said it
stand by that it's hysterical fantastic
joke came up with by John Lasseter I
think I heard yeah somebody said he was
the guy that was like a [ __ ] bb-8 go
like this is that because
not to a Wally to also have the little
[ __ ] thumbs-up thing every robot in
the know oh so maybe he didn't suggest
it they just stole it from Wally or
unless Jen laughs it was like you know
would make us awesome give that real
back here with thumbs up because robots
thumbs up Aang did he do did Wally do
that in Raleigh with a lighter I know it
was a lighter but I remember there was a
thumbs up
II mean e8 is a very very very distant
prototype of Wally
Wow
[Music]
all right so Eva Eva Eva the last Jedi
introduced us to pictures of the ports
they also in the aw sack of coverage
they also introduced us to the
caretakers mm-hmm little troll like
figures as you can see here that take
care of things they take care of like
the Jedi Temple where Luke has been
living for the last few hundred years or
whatever fate take care of business
yeah that's right they take care of
their customers and then it's like it's
lonely on this hill for us we're doing
the show
so we've seen porks in the pictures
we've seen their two caretakers you've
seen the praetorian guard
yes milks Praetorian guards [ __ ]
looks like Daft Punk's in the movie they
got real [ __ ] cool helmets and [ __ ]
but yeah as the first stormtroopers
don't look like stormtroopers they look
across three stormtroopers in the
Emperor's world indeed I'm in red mmm
Red Hots
what was his face gonna be back in it
since Darth Vader jr. oh yeah well we
knew kylo kylo Ren
that's all picture his ass mmm
with flat hair han Solo killing piece of
[ __ ] spoilers
if you're one of the people who didn't
see Forks away of unz boys organs I
don't know if you know this or not but
they killed on kilt the [ __ ] out of him
sorry his son did it
crazy Shakespearean even looking good
young board on board yeah there's
nothing to really say no [ __ ] movie
already stop teasing us man
can't wait to see it I've read a report
John boyega said that he saw he plays
been in the mood he saw Carrie Fisher's
footage described as very moving it's
her last scene in the movie now so I
can't wait I'm ready my Death Star is
coming around and it's hitting the
[ __ ] the rebel base on you haven't
that know for a fillable but it was good
watching it I think it was fun
December I felt like dak in the
beginning of that metaphor and I just
get kilt the [ __ ] out of him the first
10 minutes of the battle
[ __ ] left behind and stepped on and
[ __ ] I feel now Dec had okay Chuong as
one man my one-man show Luke on ha
you'll be able to watch at scum and
villainy JC has a club JC who shoots the
show we've shot there before we did we
did we did the Guardians episode there
we're gonna shoot there again live show
last time we did it was just closed set
yeah we're gonna if you've never been to
scum and villainy it's on what Sunset
Hollywood Hollywood sunset hollow Wanga
San Hollywood and Cahuenga and it's a
bar that looks like a bar from a famous
movie that you've enjoyed as a child
particularly in 1977 pubes that fine
together we are going to do yeah way to
get through the asteroid field of
references that that way we're gonna do
live fat man on Batman there we are at
what's the day September 16 September 16
tickets Saturday night tickets will go
on sale shortly that's East mod.com
yeah you want to come see the show you
want to come to the bar at bars [ __ ]
cool um come on the bar drinking then
watch us do a show we're way funnier
when you're drunk so we gotta do
Kamel come to the bar that'd be amazing
picture mark hamill in that bar with
[ __ ] worth forty thousand clicks on
Instagram I bet you we could command
house wards yeah I mean he's like seven
years old we could just tell me we're
going to like the supermarket I don't
know him all right I'm pretty sure we
could be a brackets at home in the van I
pity the fool that ever listen to a live
episode of fat man I'm Batman
on another plane that's coming villainy
all right enough about story let's talk
about other movies yeah the Deadpool
they were in a world of showing pictures
let's show some more Ryan Reynolds is
just jerking his social media dick and
letting all this wonderfulness fly out
of it all over the face neck and chest
of the internet last week we had Domino
this week plenty of cable playing cable
premium cables embedded his tweet cable
we got to see what josh brolin looks
like in character they did a little
light up I though I picture whatever
looks cool
fucking-a I'm there so pay attention is
social media right now just giving it
away they're shooting up in Vancouver
right now I'm heading up to Vancouver to
direct another episode of Supergirl show
I'm gonna do that in theory but most of
the time you're looking around for hey
where's Deadpool shoot what you got over
there I want to see Tim Miller they'll
be like whoa you need to turn back
around in here that's a segue Tim Miller
the amazing kid director of the first
Deadpool movie that boy Tim Miller who
turned out to be 50 I met Tim at the
screen junkies mmm
vent at San Diego comic-con screen
junkies live where I did movie fights
right before movie fights they did you
know honest trailers live I think with
Tim Miller oh that's cool
and I think maybe Rob Liefeld but I know
Tim Miller was there so I got to talk to
him in the green room you know cuz he
knows I'm a big fan and [ __ ] I just sat
there and sucked his dick about [ __ ]
oh my god that movie dude that's amazing
and he did that game you know commercial
in the game for that Batman game the
Arkham game where they showed like his
him as a young boy and then bang you
heard a gunshot and see the flash and
his expression drops and then they keep
cutting - Bruce Wayne growing up you
know and reading the letter from his
father like I hope you don't spend you
know that was a different this was just
like on the boys face and you can tell
someone's holding his hands like his
parents and then you hear the gunshot in
his expression change you see the flash
and his expression changes then you hear
the gunshot again and you see Bruce at
the funeral their clothes on his face at
the funeral and it's raining and he said
and then boom he's in like prep school
and like he's getting into a fight and
[ __ ] and then boom he's an older man
then boom he's training to become the
Batman and then boom he's the Batman
[ __ ] it was like the commercial was
better than like almost any Batman movie
they'd done you know except for the
nolan stuff so it was pretty [ __ ]
wonderful so i've been a fan of tim's
for a long time he comes from video
games mm-hmm but i love Deadpool and i
also just love the fact that Tim was
like I want to make a movie never did it
before I'm 50 [ __ ] it I'm gonna go for
it and he did it and he made a fantastic
[ __ ] flick but he's not on Deadpool -
for whatever reason creative differences
I think that's a mistake
but whatever [ __ ] me in the mouth so
what's tim miller up to Tim Miller do
Tim Miller working with James Cameron
don't worry he got a fine consolation
prize but not doing Deadpool - he's
making that Terminator movie with James
Cameron the last Terminator movie yeah
or at least the last beginning of in
this year yes guy dance
the production company that's owned by
Larry Ellison I think or Larry essence
kid one of the Ellison boys one that's
not Megan Ellison Ryan
yes basically the I who founded Oracle
has two kids who both have hundred
millions of dollars of the disposal to
make movies they both start a movie
company god bless him and so skydance
got the rights to terminator they
brought James Cameron back and James
Cameron brought in Tim Miller to kick
off a whole new scene now it's the only
job though what else is he doing he just
signed today as of the day were
recording all this knife right right to
direct a feature adaptation of
Neuromancer the William Gibson the bill
Gibson book the Billy Gibson book which
basically cyber monk the phrase
cyberpunk that kicked off an entire
genre of fiction do we like to finish
each other's sentences like a good old
couple didn't I tell you to leave mark
alone naca yeah so he's adapting
Neuromancer which is a Hugo and nebula
and multiple [ __ ] award-winning book
that sort of just kicked off that entire
virtual reality internet craze it's like
Johnny mnemonic stuff Johnny mnemonic is
also a William Gibson book when were you
ever into I read I read the first couple
of those books I read Neuromancer in
count zero not to be confused with
steampunk no cyber and steam are very
different kinds of did steampunk come
after cyberpunk they bite off that term
I mean I think the cyberpunk was the
whole beginning of the punk Suffolk's
mmm-hmm when it came to when it when it
came to fiction but I think cyberpunk
was first although I think you could
probably argue that Frankenstein is
steampunk in a way yeah that is an
cyberpunk to because he's also kind of
technically no he doesn't have any
electric parts he's just dead body parts
but they did bring him a life of
electors you've got the boys you've got
the bolts that's right he's a cybernetic
[ __ ] he's a cyborg Frankenstein's
original cyborg yeah we just said it
done solved I think the problem phase in
this movie is the fact that much like
when you got to John Carter of Mars yeah
you realize that so much of that imagery
had been stripped mined by other or goes
on the channel earlier this year
you know like we've seen the internet I
mean in the book they refer to the
connected Internet as the matrix and
it's like we've kind of already seen my
matrix yeah so are they gonna call it
now yeah they're like the thing tricks
the grid no [ __ ] you stole from the legs
like they stole from us it's a long tale
here this is why we never tried before
you know who's gonna make it work though
this [ __ ] kid Tim Miller this
wunderkind straight out of college he's
got the world by the balls he's gonna
make a great movie that Deadpool movies
fantastic it proves that's why you want
to give young people money yes
by the way to Miller's big banners I'll
see it dude I'll be honest with you
Allen you know I saw Johnny mnemonic in
a theater so I paid to see that I was
probably I don't know if I could have
said that I would definitely go see this
had it been somebody else but that it is
Tim Miller you got my money right now
I'm done with this show I'm going
downstairs to tell my wife honey we have
a date I don't know when it comes out
but we're going to see Tim Miller's
latest movie in 2020
you and me kids like you always come
downstairs with the blood all Randy DUP
after you do that show with my that mark
barnard he's a bad and she said what the
[ __ ] I'm like I'm like in Game of
Thrones like after Circe was like you're
gonna [ __ ] die in this cell and then
she went downstairs and [ __ ] the [ __ ]
everywhere that's what happens here like
we get all hot and bothered doing the
show and then I go downstairs let's see
it's Josh Brolin we've done oh this is
interesting
they're making a Hellboy movie that is
making it director Neil Marshall from
The Descent Dog Soldiers oh I like that
yeah no I like Dog Soldiers yeah it's
good [ __ ] flick he's making a movie
he's making a movie who also directed if
I remember correctly the Battle of
Blackwater episode of giving the Game of
Thrones what was that that was in like
the third season where Tyrion is left to
to defend against Stannis Baratheon
it's the hatchet face yeah any [ __ ]
defends the city yeah with the Wildfire
sure
it's great episode yeah he was that guy
my god that shows that so many episodes
of you guys I'm gonna watch the episode
I mean I feel like honey we're gonna
have sex and then I'm gonna watch it bro
she's like nine have sex with yourself
and then watch Game of Thrones in your
office my honey fare enough I'm going to
sit on the Iron Throne very winter is
coming in so my okay Tim Miller at Milla
Jovovich is going to be the Blood Queen
inhale boy :
the Blood Queen and Hellboy is not going
to be Ron Perlman but the guy from
strange Avett Harbor right and that's
great he's great and strangely I like it
is an actor which is like I don't like
him as a person fuck'em he's an evil son
of a [ __ ] took my parking spot but I
liked his acting I liked him as an I've
heard he's a lovely man is he I've heard
good to hear he doesn't have to be it's
nice it is good that he is but he's
playing howl boy and Milla Jovovich is
playing the blood queen is playing the
villain of the picture and she's had a
very long career doing weird Rando
science fiction stuff you ain't kidding
man started in first movie I think was
Dazed and Confused wasn't it or return
to the Blue Lagoon oh I think it was
return to the Blue Lagoon was the first
movie and then Daisy fuse and then
disappear for a little bit become a
model and then she like start doing like
what Resident Evil 5th element that's
right she's like Gaga get that little
monkey yeah yeah he tackled on she
didn't ever language the first multipass
that's good movie yeah did you see
valerian no we're part of the problem we
are part of a problem I did three movies
when I got back from from our London
Lodi bath did you I saw what you called
it the London like even named the London
Lottie to the London let it out the
rondelay overseas what were the three
movies that you saw the Dunkirk
the Dunkirk the Dunkirk which I liked
quite a bit Chris Nolan Chris no a
little emotionally holo Placid did
Batman show up
no but Bane did yeah Tom Hardy's uh-huh
fuckin'-a he's a fighter pilot project
get us the [ __ ] out of here
I'm the pilot of a Spitfire I can't
believe we're big
good possibilities well purchased baby
the grass on this Beach could be pain
you got a microphone is very easy okay
so you saw Dunkirk and thumbs up
I saw the thumbs up for the Dunkirk I
got that still atomic blondie how was
that
atomic blonde feels like it's a good
time but is it really Oh Oh put that on
a poster kids like it feels like it's a
john lecarre a it feels like it's like
deep Cold War it said during the like
1989 the week before the Berlin Wall
Falls isn't this the guy's the did John
wick it's one of guys David Lee cheated
John wick is he also now directing
Deadpool to do good what is the idea
cold war movie it's called war movie
where Charlize Theron plays a British
agent who was sent to Berlin oh sure I
buy was Bernie say I buyers anything
she's damn good action she really is and
she's great in it she's great in it
there's a lot of action lately and you
can like they're they're pushing her in
this one and there's lots of scenes of
her like shirt off just a lattice of
scars on her back and bruising and dude
she I mean look Tom Hardy is amazing but
she pretty much don't [ __ ] show in
that Mad Max movie like in fury road
yeah she's fantastic I watched it he was
a lot of action she put her in a Marvel
movie remember at one point they were
talking about she might have been
Captain Marvel for brie Larson somebody
it's a deep espionage movie it's very
much like Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy who
ever seen that it's all about shifting
allegiances and information being
transported smuggling and forgery and
cons not a gunplay movie looks like one
of them not a ton of gunplay there's
like four great action scenes punctuated
by long stretches of intrigue and if
intrigue floats your boat
my dog just scuffed it said in all right
that was the second movie and then I saw
Dark Tower who I did it and it is were
you a reader of that book I was I read
the first three Dark Tower novels or
seven this Stephen King has a problem
ending stories good for him
dudes prolific very much so he wrote the
entire novel over the word or two Cujo
in a weekend on a coke binge
he's a Judas I'm not making
he said that he he sat down on
typewriter and woke up on Monday morning
and there was a bunch of napkins with
blood on them in the garbage and a novel
finished manuscript on his desk and he
has no memory whatsoever of writing Cujo
there you go kids
the secret to writing is a mountain of
cocaine 48 hours to yourself box of
Kleenex so the dark tower like it's a
fine why a movie about like this kid in
Manhattan whose father died and his
mother's remarried and he doesn't get
along with anybody in school and as
these dreams of another world that he
wishes he could visit and lo and behold
a portal opens up in some weird place in
the middle of the Brooklyn and he walks
through it and finds himself in in mid
world and there's [ __ ] rolling the
gunslinger and together they've got a
run and kill the man in black before he
brings down the tower that'll destroy
every world that Hannah blacas Randall
Flagg right no and this one his name is
Walter the [ __ ] yeah I thought supposed
to be Randall Flagg I mean Randall Flagg
is Stephen King's sort of all-purpose
saying yeah like he's just the bad guy
who's in the stand and who's here and
there everything she's the reason why we
have [ __ ] captain trips absolutely
[ __ ] Flag goddamn [ __ ] Randall
Flagg also the reason the reason that
that's where I got the name for Randall
from really yeah and already the stand
yeah I want to see that [ __ ] as a movie
man I mean I think they keep talking
about that know they got close
Josh Fault in Our Stars now he's doing
New Mutants right but for he was looked
like he got close with the stand could
still happen yeah so like the movie we
get is a sort of why a movie by like my
pet gunslinger and was that any of the
books not really especially not the
first book the first book as a kid was
created the kid is a character that
shows up later on that spoilers
five-four-three-two-one in the books
roland let's die and part of that death
is what propels him finally to confront
the man in black in this one it's I
found the kid and hey we killed the man
in black we they got rid of the man in
black in the movie already yeah that's
that's it that's it what's the TV show
supposed to be but there's talking about
doing a spin-off TV show right the TV
show is supposed to be about role
early adventures about him forming his
first band of brothers and going out and
questing in the sort of mid world and
sensing out evil or whatever the [ __ ] I
don't know it is not a particularly good
dark tower movie because you make one
great decision you cast a drizelda who's
amazing and then you don't make the
movie about a Joe Salva which is bananas
how is it not about him it's about the
kid it's about the kid is this kid's
journey less about the Haunted you know
gunslinger who's forsaken the name is
his father and he was you know forgotten
his mission and doesn't do anything he
needs to do until he finally remembers
he has to do well then kills a man I'm
black by the end of the 90 minutes and
it's just what a cell I'm trying my best
but he it made what 19 million dollars
opening weekend enough a first place in
the summer that was the first place move
as a first summer time did anybody
expect this to do well I'm not saying
like I'm not you know judging I'm just
I'm not I have not not having read the
book and having no skin in the game or
horse in the race so to speak was anyone
I mean expectations had been lowered for
a good long time about what this movie
would be but the Dark Tower series is a
global bestseller like its while not
lower the Rings is in the top 20 of book
series that have sold over the course of
history there's a huge [ __ ] audience
for this if you do it right they just
didn't do it right and so you get 19
million dollars opening weekend you're
in right from the Bernardin's mouth
you've been Bernard and did alright wait
for that one and then finally Haru
Nakajima I think yeah an actor who
gained fame for suiting up as Godzilla
he was the man in the center of the
rubber student council Oh g-god Zoo oh
gee Godzilla is dead 88 he passed away
long life yeah this is long before
there's CGI there was a guy in a rubber
suit walking around stepping on little
buildings and stuff
part of our Chucky remembers which I
just said that part of our movie history
our heritage
ya know wasn't ours came from Japan
dinner in Japan it just like a good
American we stole it made it ours their
first great export
yeah truly
and this dude had been in like Seven
Samurai and he was an accurate Kurosawa
player but best known ultimately for
crushing paper mache holy [ __ ] dude is
more it listen to this after the success
of the original which was directed by
Ichiro Honda Nakajima went on to play
Godzilla a dozen times his final outing
was godzilla vs. gigan in 1972 as
stuntman and contract player for Toho
studios they made all those Godzilla
movie Nakajima starred in several other
kaiju monster movies he played Mothra in
61 and King Kong in King Kong escapes
also appearing in War of the gargantuous
and Frankenstein conquers the world this
guy was a [ __ ] legend and you didn't
know his name
goddamn it he's gone it's a shame I just
learned about who he was and he passed
away
that's tremendous man got to remember
your elders man we didn't get here by
accident that suit was heavy no [ __ ]
[ __ ] so long Godzilla thank you for all
your hard work I wish I could do that
too little girls will be singing you to
your rest good that is a pleasant image
in it though that's how I hope I die
that's everything we got man that is I'm
back next episode what's nice more [ __ ]
and we read on the Internet you went big
on that web good thank you I was trying
to win an award nice just for your
consideration
same bat-time same bat-channel spot
guest calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you